Трохи листя салату на закуску - своїх курей
Матьє Лоран щодня панькає якимись смаколиками зі свого столу.
Головна страва сьогодні - спагеті карбонара.
Всі харчові відходи сім'я Лорана скормлює куркам,
а ті не особливо перебірливі.
Вони з'їдають всі наші харчові відходи.
Все, що раніше зазвичай опинялося у смітнику.
Єдине, від чого відмовляються кури:
Шкірки від бананів, ківі та сире картопляне лушпиння.
Але, окрім цього, вони їдять справді все.
Курятник Матьє, машинобудівник за освітою, збудував сам.
Три роки тому його сім'я прихистила в себе першу курячу пару.
Тепер пернате сімейство налічує вже вісім курочок.
Усіх їх Матьє подарувала міська влада Кольмара.
Курок цілком безкоштовно може отримати будь-який мешканець міста.
Влада роздаровує курей для переробки харчових відходів.
З єдиною умовою: люди повинні брати бодай двох
курочок і забезпечити їм гідні умови життя.
Ідея до вподоби також сусідам сім'ї Лоран.
Так діти навчаються, що яйця ростуть не в супермаркеті і не в упаковці.
Маєш курей, щодня свіжі яйця, а через два роки -
гарних товстеньких курочок.
Місто Кольмар зі своєю концепцією сміттєпереробки
вважається передовиком у регіоні.
Ідея використовувати курей для поїдання харчових
відходів користується успіхом.
Місто роздало таким чином вже 1600 птахів.
Для експертів зі сміттєпереробки акція себе вже окупила.
Одна курка може з'їдати до 300 грамів
харчових відходів на день.
Одна людина спричиняє щодня близько 150 грамів таких відходів.
Таким чином, курки знищують загалом кілька сотень
тонн відходів лише в регіоні довкола Кольмара.
Повернімося до курок сімї Лоран.
Матьє вони тішать не лише своїми сміттєпереробними функціями,
але й побічним ефектом:
курочки несуть в середньому вісім  яєць на день.
Лише вночі вони приходять сюди спати
або вдень, аби знести яйце.
Увесь інший час вони надворі.
Принаймні сім'я має тепер достатньо яєць,
аби експериментувати з новими рецептами.
Донька, приміром, найбільше полюбляє омлет
зі свіжих яєць з бананами та мюслі.
Самих курок можна теж приготувати - але через два роки.
Утім, така ідея не подобається дружині Матьє.